you shared your story of being
sexually assaulted uh by your doctor
which obviously you and i
you know shared years earlier with the
world
late in the campaign it was late 2020
uh and that was such like a a
massive decision on your part i think
that's when really
most people got to know you uh
and i was obviously part of
some of that process but can you talk
people through
what that process was like for you and
how you actually arrived at
the decision to stand in front of the
world or or share your experiences with
so many people
i never imagined having um the kind of
platform
that we did and this had been
a burden on me just a secret
that i had been carrying for many years
ever since i was pregnant with
christopher
and um you know being on the trail was a
very very empowering
experience on many levels first
there were so many women
actually who were sharing their stories
of harassment of assault
with me in particular and i remember
thinking
wow you guys are so brave
and i have my own story to share um
but i was too scared you know to do it
but i felt empowered by them
empowered by the love and support
um that came to us just from you know
the campaign and i also felt this
incredible obligation um to use the
platform that i had at that moment
and try to support other other women and
other survivors
so i do feel like it was
the moment that um enabled
you know my coming forward it was rough
though
i i remember wrestling with it for
a long time and i think you know the
week leading up to
my cnn interview i probably lost 10
pounds
um but i'm so glad i did that and i
absolutely did not anticipate
um so many other women
coming forward about the same doctor
right like dozens and dozens of women i
think
over he was practicing for over 20 years
thinking about
how many women he abused during the
course of his career is just chilling
and to know that i
helped that many other women um
come forward about something where like
me they probably thought they were
completely alone maybe it was something
that they did
um yeah that means i mean that that's
everything i do remember the days
leading up to your interview
and i just wanted to be supportive i i
just wanted to say whatever you want to
do
um though i
too saw the love and support you were
getting on the trail even before you
came out with the
uh story about what happened with dr
haddon
and you were getting all these messages
about different issues that women were
facing
but after your interview it was
10 or 20 times that where everywhere we
went
women would just come to you sometimes
in tears
talking about their own experiences it
was overwhelming
the support that you got but also the
level of pain and struggle that so many
women faced i mean i i was
a witness to people coming to you so
many times
and i was so proud of you baby uh
i mean i was somewhat overwhelmed too by
the level of
attention that your story received
rightfully so but i felt like
everyone saw that interview
i got text messages from dozens of our
friends
and and this actually hit me and i'm
sure you did too
where dozens of of our friends texted me
and said i'm so sorry i never knew and
then
uh it dawned on me i was like oh yeah
like now our friends would know
uh that that this had happened and i
thought well like
i've known and like i struggled with it
for years with like the anger and pain
and
guilt on my part um but then
after you shared it uh so many other
people knew
and it and it touched so many people so
for so profoundly that i feel like you
couldn't help but feel
like it was a tremendous thing to do
because i feel like you set a lot of
people free i feel like you liberated a
lot of women
well i certainly did so for um
other survivors of this doctor um that i
know and
and i was kind of smiling when you when
you said
um you know people coming up to us
because i remember very distinctly that
after my interview you know we would do
events
and you know you would have your own
selfie line and then i would have my own
and it was beautiful but also incredibly
um telling of how just
many of us are walking around with this
trauma
and um a lot of tears and a lot of
support for one another it was that was
something that i was not anticipating
at all i didn't know that coming
or sharing a story of myself would mean
that other people would
want to share with me to that level and
um and i actually feel so grateful for
the experience because it's
it's even more um i think healing for me
to channel some of that trauma
and and be able to help other people
deal with theirs
catharsis i think is the word like it's
cathartic yes
absolutely and i think that's what we
need more of right
and it's the reason why we encourage
survivors
to share their stories because it's a
burden off them and it also
helps other people because it just opens
the door
to uh more people sharing you know i
work with
um you know rain they're the largest
anti-sexual assault
network in the uh in the country
and they tell me so they run a 24 7
hotline where you can
talk to someone train confidentially
time of day and they say that after me
too every all of the work that we've
been doing over these past years
it's not that the calls decline the
calls just increase
because the more people come forward it
the more
other people want to come forward you
referenced that a number of women came
forward about dr haddon
i know it was dozens of women it was
over 40 and
that had a real impact on his treatment
and
that case uh the the
federal government ended up uh
investigating him
as a result of all of these women coming
forward
that that must have been incredibly
gratifying for you
it was it was the first time i felt like
what he did was actually taken seriously
and so i'm very very grateful
that he was actually arrested and he's
being investigated
um for abusing minors under his care
awful yeah yeah and um
and i think they called him at the press
conference a predator
in a white coat and i had not heard him
up until that time uh ever described
that way
and it illustrated to me just
how they finally understood
um his mo right
that this was calculated you know he
would prey on
pregnant women like me
[Music]
who um in my first pregnancy
was very unaware of how
these visits were supposed to go and
then also
young women for their first visits
now he's being described as maybe one of
the most prolific
predators in the state and he was very
very close to getting away with it
and he he didn't thanks to you and so
many other women who came
forward uh i despise
this man and his existence uh and i know
i speak for so many people when
i say thank you evelyn so now to
something a little bit
more uh current and and
positive uh how did this book come about
i know that that you were at least
thinking about it but then
i think someone reached out to you i had
this book in me
pretty much as soon as i started talking
about
what happened with me with the doctor it
was because i
was looking for a way to explain what
happened to me
to our kids and also um
protect them from something that i knew
was
quite prevalent i did not realize the
extent of it you know it's
one in four girls and one in six boys
will be sexually abused before age 18.
that's a lot that that's astoundingly
high yes there are
over 40 million americans right now um
who have experienced sexual abuse
and it's not something we talk about
right it's so taboo it's so
uncomfortable
from what i was seeing there wasn't a
like a consumer
resource for for this like a a book
for parents or educators or
families um you know i'm
i'm not a doctor or clinician and
this book is not a clinical book um
usually the subject matter usually comes
across in a more clinical way
which i had a hard time with this book
is written
in the point of view of a survivor me
and it's the book that i wanted to read
to our kids
[Music]
you